okay we know Donald Trump is obsessed
with his crowds the downfall of press
secretary former press secretary Sean
Spicer really started hours into Trump's
presidency when Trump forced Spicer to
parade out there and just tell straight
up lies about the size of Donald Trump's
inauguration crowd yesterday Donald
Trump went to Texas to the hurricane
Harvey ravaged Texas and he did not talk
about the now 15 casualties as a result
of hurricane Harvey but he did take it
as an opportunity to talk about the
crowd sighs Trump did a briefing with
the Texas governor Greg Abbott and then
afterwards he spoke to a crowd it was
like a hundred or so people who were
just kind of they knew Trump was doing
this briefing and they wanted to see him
I guess even though a lot of them were
protesters holding signs and it's
unclear if these people showed up
spontaneously or if at least the ones
that were pro Trump were organized the
way you might organize a political rally
we don't really know but the point is
this is a hurricane relief event Trump
is supposedly going to bring comfort to
people to assure the victims that things
are going to be dealt with properly and
he praises the size of the crowd take a
look at this
[Applause]
we love you you are special we're here
to take care it's going well and I want
to thank you for coming up we're gonna
get you back and operating immediately
Thank You everybody what a crowd what a
turnout this has been a total
cooperative effort again we will see you
soon I will tell you this is historic
it's epic what happened but you know
what it happened in Texas and Texas can
handle anything
thank you all folks thank you it's like
he's at a Super Bowl victory rally
congratulating the winning team crowd
sighs again total unabashed unashamed
narcissism but-but-but Obama did the
same thing right after Deepwater Horizon
Obama showed up and praised the 50
people that were there oh wait no he
didn't oh but okay Obama played golf
during Hurricane Katrina
oh wait Obama wasn't president during
Hurricane Katrina doesn't matter
polling still shows that a lot of
Republicans blame Obama for the bogus
response to Hurricane Katrina
I'm almost at a loss for words here I
think it's because Trump has these go to
applause lines when he really doesn't
know what to say so on the campaign
trail it was all about how we were going
to build a wall and Mexico is going to
pay for it and crooked Hillary we can't
really use that anymore so now he's
talking about crowd sizes you just
expect that not to be said in such a
setting like this now if Trump praised
the crowd size and maybe showed some
empathy towards the victims of Hurricane
Harvey many of whom have been displaced
some of whom have died that would be
slightly less disgusting but Trump
didn't mention that 15 people died he
just didn't say a word about it tens of
thousands of people displaced nothing
endless millions of dollars in damage
nothing people without homes and just
not a word but there's a couple hundred
people there maybe a hundred some of
whom again were protesters against Trump
and Trump praises the crowd and
obviously also you see him wearing his
USA branded hats and someone else with
him was wearing one of the make America
great again I believe but that's just
par for the course and as another
example of what
said and just the guy is completely out
of touch in a depraved way he said to
Texas governor Greg Abbott during the
the briefing that they held quote we
won't say congratulations we don't want
to do that we'll congratulate each other
when it's all finished but you have been
terrific congratulations this is a
disaster our infrastructure for dealing
with these events is a total train wreck
Trump has done nothing to improve that
even though he campaigned on improving
infrastructure and his entire demeanor
it's like this was a sporting event not
a devastating and deadly crisis check
out one tweet from Donald Trump that he
put out about this historic rainfall in
Houston and all over Texas floods are
unprecedented and more rain coming
Spirit of the people is incredible
thanks it's almost like saying historic
victory by the New England Patriots
scoring was unprecedented and points
keep showing up on the scoreboard spirit
of the team is incredible it's like the
guy is emotionally just not there
whether it's his inability to empathize
with an individual homeless person next
to Trump Tower where he's been working
for who knows how long or endless
numbers of people in Houston in the
Houston Texas area that have been
ravaged by the storm he can't relate
he just can't relate it seems like it
the the positives when it comes to the
White House's response to this hurricane
has been that it does seem like adequate
funds have been attributed to the storm
and I guess response sure and also that
he chose to go to Corpus Christi where
the storm has passed and not to the
epicenter of the storm which is Houston
sure because they're still dealing with
it and if the president goes there this
is sole security detail and you're
taking away funds where they could be
better used to help the people there
silver also words do matter and it's
just such an easy softball to talk about
the victims and the loss and the tragedy
of what happened how do you not include
that somewhere in the speech when you
talk about the crowd size and this crowd
size that size thing it's just an
obsession for Trump last week there was
kind of a small crowd at a rally that
Trump did in Phoenix and Trump was
reportedly furious with a staffer
his name George JG Coase org is eco sore
jig eco so I'm not exactly sure how it's
pronounced whose Trump's advance man at
these rallies and Trump was reportedly
so angry with George that he kicked them
off of working on those rallies Trump I
guess was watching TV a couple hours in
advance of the rally and understandably
there weren't that many people at the
venue hours in advance of Trump showing
up and he became irate and completely
lost his marbles that this is what the
president is most concerned by and it's
absolutely disgusting I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman if you have thoughts on this
today's program is made possible in part
by Blue Sky binary forex trading major
major spaced millions of traders trading
Forex around the world 80% of them lose
money you need to understand basic
proper money management rules you need
to understand how to avoid getting
emotional in your trading you need to
have the appropriate base of knowledge
for forex trading and blue sky binaries
education course provides exactly that
blue sky binary is a leading financial
education and tech company they focus on
FX and they've got senior traders with
real trading experience offering a
structured and self-paced course and
that includes video on-demand it
includes online tests one-to-one
education sessions access to their
community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and my viewers
and listeners can register right now at
blue sky binary.com slash David to get a
one-week free trial which includes not
only access to their platform and
training materials but also a session
with a senior trader to get you up to
speed on the basics of forex trading
continue as long as you want for $99.99
a month after that stop cancel resume as
you wish you can get the one week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David